the outer worlds gives the player many
weapons to use like assault rifle
shotgun pistols and a spade
so let's beat the outer worlds using
only the starting weapon I sat for
minutes thinking about stats since I
hadn't really prepared an idea in my
head beforehand so I settled with what
you're seeing on screen everything was
somehow changed if you ask me why chose
these attributes honestly I still can't
give you an idea why I put some skills
and arranged for handguns and some
stealth which was completely useless
later for character creation I decided
an Arthur Morgan 1 because they pistol
owned the gunslinger sounds like a
really cool idea in my head and the fact
that read that had been overheating my
brain and CPU the last week or so going
into this I felt as excited as a
youtuber reaction thumbnail and was
ready to start my future as the cowboy
journey before I had two steps I needed
to accomplish the first step was a gun
the second step was a cowboy hat the Hat
wouldn't come from much later so we had
to wait and come back to that within
minutes we got our first trusty handgun
and we are on our way to mow down some
of these Marauders and while we do that
I'm gonna go over the rules rule 1 is
only using the starter pistol this means
this specific pistol no other spacers
choice pistol is allowed meaning I have
to be careful what mods I put on and as
usual companions are allowed but they
cannot kill which we could simply do by
setting them in passive mode this game
wouldn't be fun because I can only use
one weapon so I could tinker with it and
grow attached to it after bombing for so
long kind of like my ex before she left
me edge water was simple when not too
many enemies that were heavy armored see
the special shores pistol is only light
ammo so heavy armor can negate loads of
damage so we need both lots of ammo and
critical damage buffs to help balance
this so we talked to read and a delayed
completed the grave site fees and got
Thomas's spacegirl engineer manga and
was off to pick a side at the geothermal
plant I liked in literally every
playthrough I've had of this game have
picked edge water on our way back I got
swarmed by a load of Marauders and this
was one of the first instances on how
tough this could be after getting back
to the botanical lab Adelaide gave me
this attitude and was mad that she could
make her corpse me anymore yeah okay
boomer with that situation done we
returned the regulator to our ship and
we're onto ground breaker since we're a
Grom breaker it seems like a good time
to mention while I'm running that
today's sponsorship is by
oh they canceled for what reason because
my jokes are corny and they fall flat I
guess they did not see that coming oh I
get it
it's alright boys it's not the first
time I've been rejected but after my
adderall had stopped working I finally
managed to make some human connection
with Jun Lee using my poor lack of
social skills by putting Parvati on the
spot and directing the conversation away
from me and watching an unfold at this
point our damage against auto
mechanicals was like sending an
Eightball text after a very long message
ineffective and practically making the
situation worse we did joomla's quests
and went to go visit gladdie the grandma
that will help you out with their
problems but it is also greedy it makes
you pay for them first and then you find
out later that you could have just done
it yourself for free if you spaced out
during that dry attempt at humor I'm
talking about the fact that she sells
nab cards so we make it two rows away it
complete the three doctors quests
essentially if you're uninformed crane
got bullied because of his poor ass
teeth so he spent years of research on a
toothpaste formula and you also need to
rescue his colleague Jamison Orson has
the most severe case of dementia on the
entire colony and needs help getting his
gun schematic back and Vaughn wants to
sell some wrapped meat for to a company
for easy money
so after gassing some wraps finding the
schematic pressing a couple buttons out
of computer and completely forgetting
about Jameson until the very moment that
I'm writing this script we make it out
of Rose way with less than six K [ __ ]
didn't have keep her going the hard way
at this point at monarch after some
upgrades I was in the state of certainty
that I could complete this game with
only the starting weapon some may call
this confidence I caught a brand new
social skill after some nice walking and
talking with the local wildlife about
their day-to-day here on the planet and
made its a stellar Bay and met Nyoka she
needs you to bring her some pills and
after realizing I couldn't speech check
the old doctor lady like my previous
playthrough I was bored so I just went
alone to Devil's Peak myself and I also
shot Sanjar as well
I made it to Ambur Heights home of the
iconoclast lots of you in my comments
we're letting me know that it's called
iconoclast and not iron class apparently
I got dyslexia my apologies if you'd
like I can make a 40-minute apology
video of me crying riddled with mid-roll
ads about a minor inconvenience that's
ruining my life like everybody else does
on this website well amber heights
I was completely interrupted by some
dumb [ __ ] at the front gate and in
retaliation I shot their leader everyone
in the camp opened fire on me as soon as
this happened I can't really tell why
finally making it to Devil's Peak we ran
through everybody killed the necessary
people talk to her ROM experience what
it felt like to be a dinosaur seconds
before extinction collapsing leader with
a pistol and finished monarch in about
15 minutes I ended up wanting to do the
board ending anyway and I wanted to get
there very quickly so I ended up buying
the seal from MU down anyway or since
the mention must have rubbed off on
Felix because he somehow happened to
repeat his entire sentence twice within
about a couple seconds the city of
snobby elitists and punchable faces
Byzantium the city of snobby elitists
and punchable faces made it to Byzantium
in no time and I needed to talk to
Sophia but the main reason I was here is
because this is where the Hat was
located so I went to the Bureau of
explorations and got the quest Halcyon
in a day and stole some lady's papers as
well as I was about to kill her Sherman
wanted a deal I felt bad that he was
named Sherman at birth and decided to
give it in his very first victory in his
lifetime so without hesitation he bent
his knees aim-down-sights steadied his
aim and blasted her he's got a [ __ ] name
but he's got a damn good shot that's for
sure
the quest Halcyon and a day has you go
to four places Byzantium Edgewater Silla
and monarch four beacons once that's
done the Explorer hat is gifted to you
by the guy at the desk and you become
the western cowboy you've always wanted
to be fast forward we talked to Phineas
for the first time and I was happy for a
change because I finally found somebody
who has a worse social anxiety than me
this man locked himself in a room in a
lab floating in space with the only way
of speaking to him is through a
standalone voice communication system
for use within buildings or small
location of buildings functioning
independently generally mounted
permanently in buildings of
aka an intercom we've proceeded to
finish up with the board side of the
game and we made it to the hope we had
lots of points and handguns persuade and
engineering before we got there Felix
asked me to talk and that sentence gave
me PTSD for when my ex the hope was
simple grab an ID card walk through
everyone jump the ship to Tartarus and
walk out with apparently nobody
questioning how they just warped to the
other side of the solar system and why
some random cowboy is running around the
ship but we made it back to the
unreliable - where I saw Sam getting
frisky with Ada emotions were mixed to
say the least I was happy for my boy Sam
but the fact that a robot I raised was
getting more action than me well let's
just say you won't be seeing this on my
list any time soon
a riot ensued at Tartarus so to help us
we convince the guard to give us his ID
card and you know how this goes we're
just gonna run right through everybody
so instead of skipping this part I'm
going to be serenading you while you
watch this intense speed run
ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding
ding-ding-ding-ding
[Music]
and after making it through everyone and
avoiding eye contact which I'm extremely
good at we talked to Phineas and start
the RAM bossfight I also forgot to
mention that I ended up upgrading my
weapon and put a plasma mod on my pistol
a [ __ ] plasma mod against an armored
opponent I'm really [ __ ] batting zero
here for a whole seven minutes I ran in
circles since I could only do seven
damage or ninety damage depending on
where the hell I hit him and I only died
at once haha well with my Cod zombie
skills came to me and after what felt
like an eternity the robot was slain I
grabbed the keycard [ __ ] up the
traditional 360 trickshot and beat the
outer world's only using the starting
pistol this was actually really fun run
the hardest part was actually just the
ending and some dialogue situation but
that's really it I thought this would be
a lot harder and this was on Normal
difficulty regardless I hope y'all
enjoyed apparently YouTube's recommended
killing people because my video of that
one shot up over the past few weeks
which is really amazing I thought that
the other one where I didn't kill
anybody would get a lot more and they
would YouTube would recommend it but I
guess YouTube's odds of [ __ ] [ __ ]
recently as always if you have any other
challenge ideas let me know in the
comments below and I'll be sure to
attempt them what that guys take care
how great should a whole feature the
video empties out
[Music]
you
[Music]